So the answer is whether or not, you can see methods that are defined in the
superclass of DiscerningBear, which is GrizzlyBear. For sobj1 you can see
attributes defined by GrizzlyBear. For sobj2, you can't, because you don't use
any attributes defined in this class. An easy way to see that is to look at
knockdowntree method, which is defined in the GrizzlyBear class. When we use
super passing into DiscerningBear, that method exists and it does what it should
do. Timber! What do we think, we'll get when we looked at for the knocked down
tree attribute for the sobj that results from calling in super passing in
GrizzlyBear. Well that attribute does not exist because it's not defined by any
super class of grizzly bear